Wanna save some time and microwave two bowls at once but there's no room?
Place one bowl on top of a coffee mug and the other on the bottom.
You're welcome.
Is your SD card stuck in lock mode?
Grab a small piece of tape and wrap it around the lock area and it's business as usual.
And speaking of removable media, if you ever lose your flash drive or SD card,...
...always name the drive your phone number so whoever finds it can give you a call.
It's hot outside and the flies are sneaking into your house to stay cool.
Don't waste your time swatting them down.
Grab some glass cleaner and pump a light mist into the air.
The ammonia will knock them out and you can clean up the mess.
Be sure to give them the proper Viking funeral they deserve.
How about a simple way to make a stand for your tablet?
Grab two clothes hangers and a paper towel roll.
Glue the paper towel roll to both ends of the hangers and voila, a simple stand.
And while we're on stands, if you wanna do the same thing with your smartphone,...
...all you need is a pair of sunglasses.
Fold them out a bit and place your phone right into the middle.
Now you can play Candy Crush in style.
Wanna make a nifty hidden storage compartment for your home?
Find an old VHS tape case and remove the insert.
Replace it with a normal photo and attach it to the wall.
You now have a photo frame hiding spot.